sí como hubieras dicho con la victoria
empezaron las felicitaciones por parte
de los máximos mandatarios de países
primero de la región tanto el presidente
palestino como el primer como el
presidente israelí también felicitaron
al máximo mandatario también lo hicieron
en el Primer Ministro de Pakistán el
presidente de azerbaiyán
alief que es un socio estratégico
recordemos de resetta y perdón lo hizo
también el Primer Ministro livio o el
Emir de Qatar entre otros desde fuera de
la región actores tan importantes como
china como hubieras dicho también animó
a Turquía a seguir en la línea de
desarrollo que le viene precediendo en
los últimos años el mismo Joe biden
también tuvo ayer palabras para quien le
felicitó por la victoria y dijo que
seguirían trabajando recordemos que
biden ya tuvo una polémica intervención
antes de ser presidente donde apoyaba al
movimiento kurdo y entrever que estaba
apoyando a la a la oposición Vladimir
Putin también se ha pronunciado sobre la
victoria del máximo mandaría mandatario
Turco Donde ha destacado que el apoyo
popular recibido es una muestra de que
su política exterior independiente ha
sido muy bien aceptada por la población
turca Alberto entre tanto Cuáles serían
los principales retos en estos primeros
días de gobierno Sí para empezar el reto
más urgente con el que todo el mundo
está de acuerdo aquí es que erdogan
tiene que arreglar la economía
recordemos que la inflación según el
gobierno es del 45% según economistas
independientes estaría en torno al 100%
también tendrá que hacer frente a la
devaluación de la lira que es una
dinámica constante en los últimos años
aún así es cierto que los expertos son
poco optimistas con la recuperación de
la divisa porque todo parte Según a de
una política económica errónea que
estaría realizando ahora mismo el máximo
mandatario Turco después también en las
relaciones internacionales erdogan todo
el mundo está de acuerdo en que ha
puesto a Turquía en el tablero
geopolítico global Si antes ya tenía un
papel también importante en la otan
tienes recordemos el segundo ejército
más grande ahora es el árbitro
recordemos en la entrada de Suecia al
Tratado transatlántico el Primer
Ministro Us cristerson se ha pronunciado
acerca de la Victoria del máximo
mandatario Turco receta y perdogan
felicitándolo y también diciéndolo que
diciéndole que están Igualmente
comprometidos en la seguridad ambos
países recordemos que ahora mismo
erdogan está vetando la entrada de
Suecia por cuestiones de seguridad
diciendo que están albergando a
disidentes que para ellos son
considerados terroristas y no podemos
olvidar también el papel mediador de
rogan en la guerra entre Ucrania y Rusia
y también sigue siendo clave en el
acuerdo del grano